[تصفيق]
لقد تم الترحيب بلحظة أمل
لسقوط الدكتاتور القديم معمر
القذافي ، لكن ما يقرب من عقد من الزمان على هذا
ما يبدو عليه الكثير من ليبيا اليوم
حطام بلد ممزق
بسبب الصراع بين طرفين متحاربين
حكومة الوفاق الوطني  أو
تدير حكومة الوفاق الوطني العاصمة وجزءًا كبيرًا من
شمال غرب البلاد في الشرق
حكومة موازية تسيطر على ما يقرب
من ثلثي البلاد بقيادة
الجنرال هولي لنصف أعلى وهي مسلحة جيدًا من
الجيش الوطني الليبي أو الجيش الوطني الليبي ،
ولا يتصرف أي من الطرفين في
عزلة و  ساحة المعركة ليبيا لديها العديد من
الأيدي في العمل ، وهي مدعومة بسخاء من
قبل الإمارات العربية المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية ومصر
اللتان تنظران إلى الإسلام السياسي على أنه تهديد
ويرون أن نصف دار
هو خط الدفاع الأخير للبلاد ،
وتنضم إليهما روسيا وفرنسا
بينما ترى حكومة الوفاق الوطني دعمًا من  تركيا
قطر وحفنة من دول الاتحاد الأوروبي مثل
إيطاليا ولكن الأهم من ذلك أنها تتمتع
بختم مطاطي لشرعية الأمم المتحدة على الرغم من أنها
لا تعيش إلا من خلال الأصدقاء الخارجيين
خاصة به وتركيا في الغالب الذين
تورطوا بشكل مباشر ، حصل الرئيس أردوغان
مؤخرًا على إذن من
برلمانه لنشر القوات هناك
إذا استمرت الهجمات النصفية ضد الشعب
والحكومة الشرعية في ليبيا ،
فلن نمتنع أبدًا عن
تعليمه الدرس الذي
يستحقه هناك  أمر بالغ الأهمية لمصالح الرئيس
أردوغان الاستراتيجية خارج منطقة
الشرق الأوسط
، مما يعطي سمعته الإقليمية كلاعب قوي بعد أن قالوا
إنه مستعد للقتال ، فنحن
نقبل بموجبه تحديًا نعلن عن
تعبئة جماهيرية لقواتنا ندعو
إلى قتال مقدس في
غضون ذلك روسيا  عززت
وجودها حول البحر الأبيض المتوسط
ن هناك عدد متزايد من ال
رتزقة الروس المبلغ عنه الذين يدعمون نصف ال
وات الموجودة على الأرض في ليبيا تد
ي موسكو أنهم لا يمثلون الدولة الروسية كم
زعموا أيضًا في أوكرانيا ول
ن من سوريا إلى ليبيا  لا تزال
استراتيجية الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين التوسعية
واضحة للولايات المتحدة
من ناحية أخرى ، كانت أكثر تقلبًا ، فقد
شنت غارات جوية استهدفت
داعش والقاعدة في عام 2015 ، لكنها سحبت بعد ذلك
قواتها وسط تصاعد العنف السياسي ،
فإن موقفها الآن ليس
واضحًا تمامًا وفي فراغ فوضى الحرب
مئات الآلاف من المهاجرين باستخدام
ليبيا.  كنقطة انطلاق خطيرة إلى
أوروبا ، والقارة في الغالب
تدعو إلى حل سياسي
للصراع الدموي بيكي أندرسون سي إن إن أبو
ظبي